hello and good afternoon from the city
of lev in western ukraine a russian
assault on a military air base here in
the west has brought the war closer to
the border with poland the regional
governor of la viv says an air strike at
the compound located 15 miles from nato
territory killed 35 people and injured
57. it is an area that has so far
avoided any russian attacks the city of
la viv has been providing a safe haven
for fleeing refugees
meanwhile british intelligence suggests
forces are advancing towards ukraine's
biggest port city odessa where our team
on the ground heard
air raid sirens early this morning we'll
hear from them in a moment
let's take a look then at russia's
latest target the missile strike hit the
yavariv military range which is 90 miles
northwest of the city of lev it's also
just 15 miles from ukraine's border with
poland
so what then is behind the russian move
to attack the west generously richard
barrons former commander of joint forces
command joins me live from the sky news
center and this is significant isn't it
uh on multiple fronts
yes it is so we're seeing the russian
military extend their campaign into the
very west of ukraine really to do two
things one is to restrict the ability of
the ukrainian air force to operate
freely and the other is to try to
intercept
the flow of reinforcements and
weapons from the west into eastern
ukraine
and certainly russia said yesterday that
they saw those supply routes as
legitimate targets um the problem is not
only can you not get that military
defensive weapons in
there's a lot of people going out that
way too towards poland and what you
don't want to do is lose confidence in
either people leaving or humanitarian
aid coming in
that's absolutely right so i i imagine
the ukrainian authorities are
being very clear about this and we'll be
moving the refugees who are heading west
towards the european union down one set
of roads and doing everything they can
to keep the movement of their military
resupplies on other routes ukraine has
the virtue of being a very big place
yes and absolutely there are other
nations as you say that could send
humanitarian aid in and refugees could
leave the country so tell us about this
facility a huge facility which has used
been been used by foreign instructors
for years
yes it's the international peacekeeping
and security center it's 150 square
miles so a very big facility and before
the war started it was used by a number
of countries to send instructors to
train the ukrainian military those
instructors left before the war started
yes the florida national guard amongst
them they were there in february
understand training ukrainian soldiers
how to use bunker busters and the
significance of this attack too uh 30
rockets 30 cruise missiles it's been
suggested so a really serious attack
presumably to take out the facility
entirely
so it seemed to indicate a step up in
the russian ability to mount an attack
from the air 30 missiles in the space of
an hour uh carefully coordinated to hit
different points of this facilities
quite a high level of proficiency higher
maybe than we've seen in other places
but at 150 square miles that 30 missiles
is not going to put the entire facility
out of operation although it's clearly
done a lot of damage and killed at least
35 people
and how concerned are you about the
proximity to poland and nato nation uh
the border really very close
so i think we need to be absolutely
clear that targets in ukraine are part
of this war underway between
russia and ukraine but even six inches
over that border into a nato country
would risk escalating the war to between
russia and nato
and article 5 will apply and i don't
think anyone is in any doubt about that
line